i kind of think that contributed to the whole
lunar love good vibe because she is a bit spacey
if you were cast in harry potter as a preteen odds
are you got to use your own voice it's leviosa not
livio but the adult cast got to play all of the
creepy villain characters and weird comedic types
we're taking a look at the actors who really put
a lot of work into their characters and didn't
really sound like themselves by the end you'd like
to cover up and um and i said you're completely
right i'm afraid voldemort isn't you darling rafe
finds took inspiration from his nephew who played
a young voldemort and no we aren't talking about
christian coulson who played tom riddle in chamber
of secrets we're talking half-blood prince tom
played by hero finds he has such a wonderful
quality of a a boy's loneliness because the world
has rejected him that snake-like whisper finds
brings to the character obviously isn't how
he talks normally you're a full harry potter
and you will lose if he actually spoke like that
he probably never would have gotten very far as
an actor as it's an intimidating enough persona
to scare the gryffindor out of daniel radcliffe
but the voice evolves throughout the series
when voldemort first receives his body and
goblet of fire he sounds like a sick and elderly
man 13 years it's been but as the character grows
stronger so does his voice severus i was
beginning to worry you had lost your way
and you would know voldy is just one character
rafe finds can play if you'd ever seen grand
budapest hotel which you totally should how's
that supposed to make me feel wait what in the
baboo frick she played myrtle in her 30s you heard
that right myrtle was played by established voice
actor shirley henderson who has since played
the little baboo in the rise of skywalker
which do you think de-aged her more the
translucent ghost thing or the bangs
because bangs were definitely the de-aging tech
of the time maybe it was the fact she was five
foot nothing or maybe it was just the squeaky
voice and it fell through the top of my head
and here's the real her when
you can't see right through her
a bit of both i mean it's exciting but it's also
a bit uncomfortable at the same time if we could
play any role in the franchise it would definitely
be bellatrix helena bonham carter definitely had
the most memorable role in the series a lot of
bellatrix's character came from helena's strong
relationship with the director who allowed her
to play and explore on set who knows how to play
itsy bitsy baby and the rest of the tone
of voice came from the fake teeth she used
which by the way she was the one who asked for the
teeth in the first place and also kept them after
filming wrapped well she's just like this mad
child which is why she doesn't brush her teeth
but there you have it helena is much more laid
back than bellatrix in real life everybody seems
to make us more interesting than we actually are
we are living for jason isaac's catty voice theft
the inspiration jason had for lucius malfoy's
voice came from two different places it came
from a teacher at his drama school that teacher
didn't give him any good acting tips no actually
the two quite disliked each other so jason just
stole his voice and then he combined it with
that of a famous art critic using a fabricated
upper-class british accent that is my true mask
no one was confident that this voice would
win over audiences but jason was and it paid
off listen to how quickly he can just jump
into character i turned to daniel and i said
let's hope mr bottom will always be around to
save the day why so serious sorry that pun was
too easy given how down to earth sirius black
really is later on in the series it's jarring
to watch his performance when he was fresh out of
azkaban i can't explain any of that it's just the
way it it's worked out amazing to think that man
created this character why don't you run along and
play with your chemistry set for gary oldman he
approaches his characters from one of two places
it's normally a vocal thing or or a physical thing
rather than just letting it be purely intellectual
it's been years since your last nightmare
about dolores umbridge two years before her
casting a friend of imeldas read harry potter
and then said she'd be perfect for the part
she read it and thought small squat ugly toad like
woman thanks a lot we wouldn't describe her voice
as toad like more like cookies scratching against
a chalkboard and not like good cookies but like
raisin cookies in case you don't remember
it and need more nightmare fuel here's your
reminder there is nothing out there dear who do
you imagine was to attack children like yourself
well imelda staunton speaks just an octave or so
lower it's not really legal but it's necessary
i think that sums her up it's also important
to see her out of costume you know they took oh
are you and i go step away step away raise your
hand if you didn't realize emma thompson played
sybil trelawny between the hair the glasses
the costume the behavior and of course the
voice we understand if you didn't recognize her
together we shall cast ourselves into the future
bet you would love to cast yourself into the past
to relay this information to a younger you huh i'm
not really in it enough to impress them okay good
then we're off the hook we didn't know it was her
if you play this video at 1.25 speed luna will
sound like ivana there's nothing exceptionally
ordinary about ivana lynch she still has that
whimsical quality when she speaks the biggest
difference really has to be the pace yvonne is
spending just a little less time in the clouds or
looking at thestrals than luna i wish i felt this
relaxed when i when i was younger actually wait
more relaxed than you were playing luna did we
hear that right no but i've done several toes
and how different are they really maybe in the
world of harry potter noses and toes are not so
different but in the doctor's office we bet
they're very different now for our favorite
grumbly caretaker filch was a fun one for david
bradley he didn't talk much but he was a huge
part of the series always there always watching
always grumbling and groaning but still finding
small moments of happiness when harry would find
himself in a pickle oh dear we are in trouble
the secret to getting the voice of the character
is the false teeth all i've got to do is just pop
these in there and it's an instant filch timothy
played a character that couldn't be farther from
himself there's something jarring about comparing
timothy spall and his character peter pettigrew
because he really gives off politician
vibes i think are we gonna see the birth
of a religion are we harry potter actually
we meant that pettigrew gave off the vibes
have no idea the weapon she
possesses yeah that's better
in all seriousness timothy put
a lot of work into the role
and a lot of his inspiration came from
pettigrew's 12 years of living as scabbers the rat
the wizarding world of harry potter truly lends
itself to some magical voice acting choices in
these lessons i will attempt to penetrate to your
mind from false teeth to art critics it just goes
to show inspiration can come from anywhere one of
turner's things on the wall and i look at it and i
think the hell did i do that i can't even remember
doing it which actor's vocal transformation
impressed you the most leave your thoughts in the
comments and thanks for joining us at the things